très très jeune même vraiment même avant
les premiers vols à l'étalage j'avais
8-9 ans pour pour manger d'abord on
avait rien alors c'est pas une excuse il
y en avait qui était aussi pauvre que
nous et que en fait c'est comme une
bonne mayonnaise il faut que tous les
ingrédients soient réunis donc voilà
l'environnement la famille c'est tout
donc moi voilà très jeune dans le volet
étage pour manger ensuite pour
m'habiller et puis ensuite bah pour
l'argent et tout et voilà je vais même
quartier que Mokhtar justement bah ouais
voilà on est très bien il faut il pourra
en parler mais mais pourquoi je cite
l'exemple c'est parce que tu vois et il
venait pas d'une famille en or très
riche et il a il a pas sombré dans le
banditisme en plus c'est pour ça faut
que tous les ingrédients soient
justement qu'est-ce que vous diriez
qu'est-ce qui fait que alors vous le
regardant familiale a été comment était
stable pas stable compliqué non c'était
compliqué mon papa était en prison
tomber dans l'alcool tout ça et bon ma
mère elle a essayé de faire ce qu'elle
peut mais c'est ça qui avait rien dans
le frigo il y avait rien donc voilà
encore une fois je cherche pas à
l'excuse je je dis juste que voilà c'est
tout était réuni pour voilà les grands
qui m'entourer ils nous ont montré le
chemin si vous s'habiller c'est la
grande surface c'est l'époque des voilà
les marques les trucs voilà on allait on
a eu trois dans le centre-ville tout ça
tout donc
il rigole parce que
j'ai traversé la route non comment
est-ce qu'on alors là on comprend c'est
des petits lapins ouais comme ça comment
est-ce qu'on passe les petits larcins à
une banque parce que ça a été votre cas
ouais en fait bon il y a aussi une étape
d'abord les les cambriolages de nuit on
on fait on fait les boutiques de luxe et
tout ça et après moi très vite je
voulais m'attaquer à l'état c'est je
voulais pas m'attaquer à au au je
voulais pas faire de victimes et je
voulais pas voilà j'ai dévalisé une
boutique de luxe et on faisait quand
même d'éviter donc j'avais j'ai eu cette
bêtise de me dire l'état même là c'était
pas bien non plus tu vois c'est c'était
il y a des banques privées voilà donc
bon voilà donc je me dis très vite je me
suis spécialisé dans le neutralisation
des systèmes d'alarme et j'ai dit à mes
potes
neutraliser l'alarme d'une banque c'est
pareil qu'un magasin ils m'ont pas cru
je l'aurais montré j'ai neutralisé la
larme on a compris
mieux que ça vous avez fait un tunnel ah
oui après donc on a fait plein de
banques plein de banques qui
réussissaient et après avec mes potes
j'ai dit on va en faire une dernière une
grosse on voulait faire le casse du
siècle à Caen voilà la SPA durant ces
attaqué au siège social de la Société
générale dans le Calvados quand même
pendant 4 mois on a creusé un tunnel
dans les égouts jusqu'à la banque
jusqu'à la salle des gorge jusqu'à la
salle des coffres film 4 mois 4 mois
4 mois de creusage avec éboulement et
tout qui vous inspirez pardon si elle
est chapeau qui vous inspire non non non
non c'est parce que comme on était
tricard en haut à chaque fois qu'on se
faisait contrôler dans le centre-ville
ou quoi j'ai dit mes potes on va aller
dans les égouts et on a vu dans les
égouts comme une ville il y a les mêmes
noms des rues
il y a eu un célèbre
il y a eu un bouquin qui s'appelle les
égouts du paradigme
parce que bon pour des raisons je peux
pas le dire dans mon spectacle
j'explique comment je me fais attraper
arrive un moment et je fais la une des
journaux il me compare à Spa de Jarry
vous êtes là vous êtes pas rentré dans
le dans la banque ouais non c'est arrivé
à la salle des coffres on était à la
salle des coffres et donc on se fait
attraper sur cinq on se fait attraper K2
et il me transfère d'un commissariat à
un autre et pendant que pendant le
transfert les les policiers ils me
comparer à spad arrive il y en a il me
dit tu as plus qu'à faire comme
Spaggiari il a mis 4 mois pour s'évader
5 minutes plus tard j'étais évadé
alors je vais vous raconter l'évasion
c'est le clou du spectacle c'est un bon
pan du spectacle donc je peux pas trop
la dire là mais c'est une évasion ou je
les ai je les ai amené à commettre une
erreur et pareil sans armes et sans
violence j'aurais fait un voltage
j'aurais fait vraiment je disais emmener
dans un entonnoir et j'ai réussi à me
sauver et là bon cavale tout ça je suis
parti en cours c'est pas vous avez fait
une gamelle qui a duré 4 ans alors la
première cette première là c'est un an
ensuite il me rattrape je je je retourne
en prison je fais 50 prison ensuite je
fais deux ans et demi dehors ou je lâche
plonge dans dans le shit à haute échelle
je me refais attraper à la frontière
espagnole avec 25 kg de cheat et je fais
2 ans je ressors en provisoire après je
passe je prends 5 ans sur 5 ans je fais
deux ans et je passe au tribunal je
pense ça fait beaucoup
on est quand même
mais donc sur cette deuxième là je passe
au tribunal j'avais fait deux ans
préventive ils me remette trois ans et
là je refais encore un tout un coup de
cinéma truc moto je pars encore en
cabane je me rabatte et là je fais là
sur celle-là 4 ans 4 ans et demi de
cabale donc votre vie dans l'illégalité
ça a duré de de quel âge a quel âge
alors j'ai commencé à 8 9 ans les
premiers volets étage jusqu'à la
trentaine quoi jusqu'à la trentaine donc
c'est 32 ans de voilà et c'est là alors
je tiens à dire j'ai un message très
important quand même parce que je suis
conscient que devant les postes de télé
les gens vont dire ouais on donne encore
la parole à un ancien bandit voleur tout
ça dans le projet lisier vous dites pas
il faut faire comme moi ce qui est vrai
c'est que dans votre cas on va raconter
vous avez essayé de de prendre un boulot
vous avez fait ou alors je crois ouais
j'ai fait et voilà et après il fait beau
et puis il retourne vers la la
délinquance des allers-retours pendant
un temps mais ce qu'il faut que tu sais
expliquer c'est comment on un jour on se
dit bon voilà j'ai fait voilà j'ai fait
15 ans ou 10 ans de placard je fais des
conneries comment est-ce qu'on on se dit
bah maintenant j'arrête fini les
conneries fini les conneries merci
Maxime déjà le déclic moi j'appelle ça
des déclics c'est c'est des déclics
c'est ce que je dis dans mon spectacle
et tout ça et en fait le déclic déjà
c'est pas dans laquelle ma deuxième
cavale pendant ma deuxième cavale je
voyais les gens qui allaient travailler
qui est en vacances sur les bases que
j'ai j'ai quand même je partais en
vacances pendant cette cavale ouais
c'est parti
sur la tête mais on dit qu'il faut
beaucoup d'argent pour il faut beaucoup
d'argent il faut beaucoup d'argent donc
c'est pour ça ah ben moi je retourne au
casse-pied j'ai retourné quoi pendant
cette appart pendant la Deuxième arrive
un moment j'ai décidé de stopper tout
j'ai vraiment décidé de de c'est là que
j'étais travailler honnêtement j'ai
travaillé je me suis comme attaché au
SAMU de Paris ambulancier ensuite je
montais sur scène sous le nom de pain lu
j'étais recherché je montais sur scène
sous le nom de palu les gens me disaient
la suite je peux pas je suis en cavale
ça mais c'est vraiment vrai c'est
incroyable et faire plonger du coup
qu'est-ce qu'il y a à faire alors voilà
là
j'étais recherché mais j'allais je
montais sur scène je travaillais au SAMU
de Paris j'avais ma femme des enfants
tout ça je voulais vraiment être droit
mais je me refais attraper je retourne
en prison je fais ma je fais ma dernière
peine à Fresnes et donc là j'ai eu mes
premiers techniques et après encore plus
de déclic là je me dis je veux vraiment
montrer une autre image à mes enfants et
aux jeunes qui sont autour de moi dans
la prison je voilà j'ai mon papa avait
été en prison moi aussi je veux pas que
mes fils il y a aussi et donc là freine
j'ai tous ces déclics encore plus et
surtout je fais rire la promenade on me
demande comment je me suis évadé la
première fois quand je raconte mon
évasion sans prenant tout le monde
rigole il irait parce que voilà j'y mets
de l'humour j'aime bien rire et tout
mais j'ai pas besoin de beaucoup de
forcer parce qu'elle est marrante
ensuite on me demande la cavale de
l'humour l'humour à chaque fois ça
rigole et là j'ai le déclic je me dis je
vais te montrer le mauvais exemple aux
jeunes qui sont autour de moi ils vont
se dire que c'est la rigolade c'est le
truc de David il a une je veux j'ai
voulu leur montrer le mauvais côté toute
cette vie mais si je commence à leur
faire la morale on dit écoute David tu
es plus marrant va et là j'ai j'ai
décidé d'en faire un spectacle dans la
promenade faire de raconter tout ça avec
plein d'humour et des dérision mais
surtout plein de messages et ça marchait
les mecs sortaient m'envoyer des cartes
en faisant David tu m'as fait quoi ce
qu'on faisait des petits débats dans la
promenade ça a porté au débat et là il
m'a envoyé des messages en disant David
tu m'as fait comprendre et il me dit là
je me suis dit si je peux leur faire
comprendre à eux en prison en étant à
l'époque prisonnier on est d'accord on
est en prisonnier autant le faire deux
avant qu'ils aillent en prison et là
donc arrivé dehors je monte sur scène et
tout je peux j'ai j'avais payé ma dette
à la société je pouvais et là je
rencontre Stomy Bugsy Véronique Guimard
tout ça au Théâtre du Gymnase plein
plein de beaux plein plein de monde très
important et pour pour ce que j'ai fait
voilà nos tests tout ça des des
personnes importantes et là je je fais
le spectacle ça marche ça marche au
début c'est dur mais ça marche et et
avec stomie on fait déjà le truc très
important les premiers qui achètent le
spectacle c'est le ministère de la
Justice ils me font et là c'est là ça a
été un truc de fou et du coup vous allez
jouer en prison dans en prison et même
dans les prisons où j'étais incarcéré et
donc on amène des débats tout ça et et
là le truc de malade je dis à stomie il
manque quelque chose et la place des
victimes parce que je voulais vraiment
faire prendre conscience et je parlais
pour les victimes je dis j'expliquais
les séquelles que les victimes pouvaient
avoir sur des cambriolages des vols même
des agressions tout ça mais je me suis
dit c'est des victimes elles-mêmes qui
doivent le faire et là avec stomie on a
décidé de rentrer en contact avec des
victimes on a rencontré une femme qui
s'appelle Marie-Ange victime de d'un
gros gros braquage on l'a ramené avec
nous dans les prisons on faisait le
spectacle et après le spectacle la
partant en débat et on a amené la
justice restaurative très très important
la justice restaurative c'est les
victimes qui ont enfin la parole et là
les victimes échanger avec les détenus
les détenus se rendrai compte ce que
c'est qu'être une victime c'était énorme
par exemple une victime un détenu il y a
une dame à la dame elle a dit Madame
c'est pas à vous qu'on s'attaque ça vaut
bien observe et elle elle lui dit elle
lui dit que texto elle lui dit comme ça
lui dit tu sais vois un cambrioche ça
dure 5 minutes mais nous c'est des
séquelles la vie quand on rentre du
travail ou de vacances on voit notre
maison on le vit comme un viol et là
l'échange entre victimes et détenus
c'est tout simplement énorme c'est vrai
que le quand vous étiez alors en cavale
mais avec un travail et une vie rangée
le juge en voyant ce que vous aviez fait
de bien a été plus clément oui oui
franchement je dois rendre c'est vrai
que hommage à ce juge parce que pour le
coup il aurait pu être valable
parce que j'étais classé récupérable et
tout il a décidé de me sortir avec le
bracelet quand il a vu mon parcours
pendant mon évasion que j'avais été sur
scène que je travaille au SAMU de Paris
tout ça il m'a donné cette chance et que
je dois voilà que là je je rends
toujours hommage donc c'est très fort et
et là ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui j'ai une petite
déception dans ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
c'est que par exemple je vais pas
remettre ça sur le tapis mais ce qui
s'est passé à Fresnes et Koh-Lanta c'est
tout ça ça nous a fait beaucoup de mal
ça nous a fait beaucoup de mal parce que
j'étais dans tout ça il y avait mon
spectacle Les Coudry avec Stomy Bugsy on
a fait avec aussi le spectacle un jour
j'avais trois mais dans tout ça il y
avait aussi Koh-Lanta c'était un tout il
y avait le spectacle il y avait le truc
des kartings il y avait aussi le rap
avec Mouloud
parce que Djibril c'est un ami à moi qui
a fait Koh-Lanta ça nous a fait beaucoup
de mal quand tu dis ça c'est pas dire
alors je m'explique c'est très important
en fait le chacun après à balancer ses
vidéos moi j'ai eu mes vidéos qui sont
encore été sur Youtube mais moi en fait
pour moi la vie c'est un lac bleu j'ai
mis du bleu dans le bleu ça ça
n'intéressait pas que je ramène la
justice restaurative que je ramène tout
simple ça a pas trop intéressé lui le
jour d'après quand il a fait koh-lanthes
il avait balancé ses images pas c'était
du rouge dans le bleu et là ça ça Moulou
de mansouris avec la star pareil donc
ils sont dit oh les on ramène que du rap
en prison ou que des kartings et
derrière ça ce qui s'est passé c'est que
le ministère de la Justice a fermé un
peu n'importe où
parce qu'on a eu raison humaine
nous raconte aujourd'hui son message son
ami professionnel parce que voilà vous
avez raconté votre vie qu'est-ce qu'il y
a après alors ce qui a après moi la
bombe bon il y a le spectacle j'ai un
autre spectacle avec stomie et tout ça
un jour j'allais trois mais il y a il y
a aussi le préparation d'une série télé
je veux faire la BO de mon spectacle on
est en plein de préparation la BO du
spectacle j'ai décomposé je vais être
alors ils disent que c'est ça n'est
jamais été enfant fait en France la BO
d'un spectacle qui a déjà eu les biodan
BO de comédie musicale avant il y a très
longtemps dans le stress et spectacle
Coluche là non faites BO quand je dis BO
c'est vraiment BO j'ai décomposé mon
spectacle en 14 titres et voilà chaque
titre chaque thème tout ça et on fait ça
va être la BO avec des rappeurs tout ça
voilà on va faire la BO il y a déjà eu
des BO de films des baux de comédie
musicale mais le BO de one man show il
paraît que ça n'a jamais été fait donc
je vais faire ça et je veux voilà la
série télé le cinéma plein de choses la
vidéo est-ce qu'on peut vous voir
aujourd'hui ah là pour le théâtre de
Paris tous les jeudis à 21h30 en tournée
demain je serai à Vannes au Centre des
arts de Vannes en Bretagne demain et
tous les jeudis à 21h30 au théâtre la
Polo comédie théâtre à Paris